ومشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في تغطيتنا
للتطورات في السودان الهدنه في يومها
الثاني لا تخلو من خروقات والازمه
الانسانيه لا تتراجع بل تزيد الصحه
العالميه دقت ناقوس الخطر استوقعت المزيد
من الوفيات في ظل نقص الخدمات مشيره الى
ان اكثر من 60% من المنشات الصحيه في
الخرطوم مغلقه لكن الخبر لافت هو اعلان
وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان ان البرهان اكد
لرئيس جنوب السداس الباكير استعداده للقاح
ماتي خارج الخرطوم وانس الباكير ما يزال
يحاول اقناع حمادي بالموافقه
انا ناس مواطنين مسالمين دارين ياكلوا
لقمه الايش
المشكله بقى خطيره علينا
[موسيقى]
الناس
المساجين
اليوم باليوم
[تصفيق]
في كرسي انا داري منكم بس تهزوا
تستبق
ومع استمرار المواجهات في السودان والجهود
الدوليه المبذوله لوقف اطلاق النار اعلن
البيت الابيض عن العمل مع طرفي الصراع في
السودان لتمديد وقف اطلاق النار لوقف
العنف وتامين المسارات الانسانيه مشيرا
الى ان وقفه اطلاق النار في السودان مستمر
رغم بعض الخروقات بالاضافه الى عمليه
القصف العشوائي التي اثرت عن مقتل مدنيين
بينهم امريكي هو ثاني حتى الان واكد البيت
الابيض على مواصله العمل لتامين خروج كل
مواطن امريكي يريد مغادره الاراضي
السودانيه
من جهته قال المتحدث الرسمي باسم الاتحاد
الاوروبي في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
لويس ميجال بوينو قال ان الاتحاد يرحب
بالهدنه الانسانيه في السودان لكنه يريد
الوصول الى وقف اطلاق نار دائم
كنا نرحب بطبيعه الحال باعلان هذه الهدنه
من سنيه في السودان بعد ايام من من الصراع
ولكن صحيح هناك اعلانات هنا هناك
لاختراقات وانتهاكات لكن نحن نريد ان نكرر
دعواتنا المتقاتله
لجعل هذه الهدنه الانسانيه لوقت لقد
وفي تطورات اخرى اعلن الجيش السوداني
التصدي لهجوم لقوات الدعم السريع على مقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم
وقال الجيش انه كبد قوه الدعم السريع
خسائر فادحه بحسب البيان واتهم الجيش قوات
الدعم السريع بمواصله خرق الهدنه المعلنه
[تصفيق]
ماشيين الهجوم
رئاسه شرطه الولايه ودين المواطنين ماشيين
ماشيين قال لهم فتحوا لهم المخازن
المواطنين العاديين دايرين يمشوا ياخذوا
لهم اسلحه من شرطه المحليه لانه ما في قوه
يعني تحميم
يحمي نفسه
هذا مشاهدينا وفشلت الهدنه كما فشلت
سابقتها في وقف اطلاق النار بشكل تام بين
الطرفين النزاع الاشتباكات وتركزت في
العاصمه الخرطومه وتحديدا في محيط القصر
الرئاسي ومناطق في محيط القياده العامه
واداره المرافق الاستراتيجيه التي تتعرض
لقصف مدفعي عشوائي وكذلك المناطق المحيطه
بمطار الخرطوم الدولي وحي المطار السكني
وفقا للجيش السوداني فان الاشتباكات
تتمركز ايضا في مناطقها في بحر وام درمان
في هذه الاثناء تحدثت الجيش السوداني عن
تحركات كثيفه لارتال عسكريه لدعم السريع
قادمه من كردفان ودارفور لتعزيز قوتها
بالخرطوم كما اتهم الجيش ايضا قوه الدعم
السريع باستخدام المدنيين في الاحياء
السكنيه دروعا بشريه
في المقابل حملت قوه دعم السريع المجتمع
الدولي مسؤوليته تجاه خرق الهدنه من قبل
قيادات الجيش السوداني مشيره الى ان عدم
التزام قيادات الجيش بالهدنه تؤكد تعدد
مراكز القرار داخل الجيش كما اتهمت قوات
الدعم السريع قوات من الجيش بمهاجمه
مواقعها بمحيط القصر الجمهوري وارض
المعسكرات وسوبا في وقت واحد
دعا وزير الماليه السوداني وزعيم حركه
العدل والمساواه جبر الابراهيم دعا الشباب
الى تشكيل لجان شعبيه لحمايه المدن
المتاثره بالحرب وقل جبريل ابراهيم في
تغريدات على حسابها على تويتر ان الوضع في
مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب دارفور
يتسم بالفوضى العارمه مشددا على ضروره
التحرك لايقاف الماساه هناك على حد تعبيره
تعبنا احنا معنا نطلع من بيوته من بيوتنا
معها نطلع في بيوتنا الموت واحد احنا
اولادنا نقوموا من الصباح عشان يجيبوا لنا
مويه لغايه بالليل مويه عشان نشرب نحن حد
وين حد وين يا ابو
خافوا الله فينا خافوا الله فينا لا حول
ولا قوه الا بالله
الامه كلها بتدعي فيكم
[موسيقى]
من جانبها عبرت بريطانيا عن قلقها ازاء
التقارير التي تفيد بان الطرفين اخفق مره
اخرى بالوفاء في التزاماتهما حول الهدنه
ودعت قوات الجيش والدعم السريع الى وقف
دائما لاطلاق النار وانهاء العنف بالاضافه
الى السماح بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه
وضمان حمايه المدنيين والعاملين في المجال
الانساني وطبي
من جانبه دعا الامين العام للامم المتحده
دع الاطراف المتصارعه في السودان الى وقف
القتال في البلاد مشددا على ان القتال لن
يكون حلا للصراع بين القوتين
دعا قاده السودان لجعل مصالح شعبهم اولويه
وان يقوموا باسكت اسلحه فورا
وفي مسلسل المعاناه السودانيين المدنيون
يشكون من رصاص الدوشكا روسي ويقولون انه
يخترق جدران المنازل ويصيبهم باصابات
بالغه نتابع
في الثلاثينات من القرن الماضي
السودان من الدول التي تستخدم هذا الرشاش
بكثره
طلقته كبيره الحجم من عيار 12.7 ملم
يصل مدى الرمي الى
3500 متر
في الاصل هو رشاش ثقيل مضاد للطائرات
يمكن استخدامه ضد المدرعات الخفيفه
والاليات العسكريه
اذا تم استخدامه في المناطق المدنيه سيؤدي
الى اضرار مروعه
وفي اخر التطورات عمليه الاجلاء من
السودان قلم رسل العربيه الى نحو سبع
طائرات عسكريه تصل يوميا الى بورسودان
للاجلاء بالتنسيق مع الجيش هذا ووصلت احدى
طائرات الاجلاء الى بيروت بمساعده
السعوديه محمله باثنين وثلاثين شخصا كما
تمر عمليه الاجلاء الى ليبيا عبر ثلاث
مراحل بريه وجويه وبحريه تبدا بالانتقال
بالحافلات الى بورتسودان ثم الى ميناء جده
وصولا الى المحطه الاخيره في طرابلس
واستقبل مطار مايتيجا دولي 105 من افراد
الجاليه الليبيه في السودان بعد اجلائهم
واكدت الجزائر ان 13 فلسطينيا 22 سوريا
وعددا اخر من الرعايه بالخرطوم قدموا من
مطار بورت سوداني
ونستطلع الاوضاع باكثر تفاصيل مع زميلنا
من جدا ومراسلنا سلطاننا السلمي الذي
يتواجد بقاعده الملك فيصل البحريه حيث
مشاهدينا تتجهز سفينه جلاله الملك
للانطلاق في طريقها الى بورتسود لمواصله
عمليه الاجلاء اهلا بك معنا سلطان نتحدث
عن المزيد من التفاصيل كيف تبدو الصوره
مبدئيا من عندك
اهلا بك واهلا بكافه المشاهدين نتواجدان
على متن سفينه جلاله الملك الجبيل هذه
الفرقاطه
العسكريه التي يبلغ طولها 106 امتار
وعرضها سته عشره مترا هذه الفرقات
العسكريه المجهزه بكافه الاسلحه المتقدمه
والتي خصصتها القوات البحريه السعوديه
لاجراء عمليات الاجلاء من ميناء بورت
السودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل هنا بجده
سوف نرافق هذه السفينه الى ميناء بورد
السودان من متوقع وصولنا في تمامه بعد من
ثمانيه الى عشر ساعات هي مده الرحله
البحريه وصولا الى ميناء بورت السودان
لاجلاء الرعايه بمختلف جنسيتهم كما نشاهد
تجهيزات كبيره على متن هذه السفينه سوف
تستوعب اكثر من 65 شخص من الرعايه بمختلف
جنسيتهم فور وصولها الى ميناء بورت
السودان العربيه سوف
نعم
انقطعت الصوره وصوت كذلك ولكن سنشترك بعض
لحظات ربما نعود لاستكمال هذا الشرح
التفصيل لزميلنا سلطاننا السلمي عادت
الصوره اعود لك من جديد سلطان تفضل
نعم هذه امامكم هذه القمره هي القمره
القياده المخصصه لعمليه
نتحدث انه من المتوقع خلال الساعات خلال
الساعه ثمانيه ساعات او عشر ساعات القادمه
سوف نصل الى الميناء بورتسودان سوف تكون
هذه هي السفينه السابعه فيما يتعلق بعمليه
الاجلال التي بدات منذ قرابه الاربعه
ايامنا في السعوديه اذا كما تحدثنا هي
مجهزه بعتاد عسكري باعلى جوده كما يظهر
امامكم امام الكاميرا قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه التي ابحرنا منها قبل دقائق
معدوده فور او وصول هذه الفرقاط العسكريه
الى ميناء بورد سودان سوف تتم عمليات
الاجلاء على متنها وسوف تستوعب اكثر من
خمسه وستين شخص يتحدث عن امكانيات كبيره
سوف نرافق هذه الفرقات العسكريه حتى
وصولها الى ميناء السودان نتحدث عن
امكانيات كبيره لهذه الفرقاط العسكريه
لحمايه كافه الرعايه التي سوف يكونون على
متنها ايضا فيما يتعلق بعمليات الاجلاء في
التي تعمل عليها السعوديه بالتنسيق مع
كافه الاطراف هناك في السودان نتحدث انه
انقطعت الصوره والصوت كذلك من جديد طبق
سلمان اسمح لي ان اعيد واذكر ببعض ما
وفيتنا به من معلومات واعود لك طبعا ستبقى
معنا هذه الصوره اعود لك بعض لحظات اذا
هذه مشاهدينا هي سفينه السابعه التي
تخصصها المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لعمليه الاجلاء انطلقت هذه السفينه من
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه متجهه الى ميناء
بورسودان كما وفانا بذلك زميلنا سلطان من
علامات من هذا السفينه هذه السفينه
الاخيره كما ذكرنا هي السابعه وهي قادره
على حمل 65 شخص هي مجهزه باخر التقنيات
وهي سفينه
ستتواجد بعد ساعات من الان في ميناء بورت
سودان للبدء بعمليه الاجلاء اعود لكم من
جديد سلطان
نعم نظرا بدانا في عمليات البحار لذلك
تضعف الشبكه بشكل واضح وكبير اثناء دخولنا
الى المياه البحر الاحمر لكنه اؤكد انه
هذه السفينه هي السفينه
القوات السعوديه التي تعمل
في عمليات الاجلاء الخاصه بالرعايه
الاجانب والمواطنين السعوديين من بورت
السودان الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحري
نتحدث على اعداد وبلغت اكثر من 2020 شهر
من ثمانيه عملت على اجلاهم الحكومه
السعوديه منذ بدء الازمه وتحديدا بدات
عمليات الاجلاء خلال الثلاثه ايام الماضيه
واخر التحديثات فيما يتعلق بعد وصول
الرعايه نتحدث انه استقبلت الحكومه
السعوديه اليوم او قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه اكبر عمليه اجلاء منذ بدء الازمه
في السودان نتحدث عن عدد ليصل الى 1667
شخص من اكثر من اربعين الجنسيه
استقاده الملك فيصل البحريه على وهم على
متن السفينه التجاريه تسمى امانه سوف
كافه المعلومات خاصه بعمليات الاجلاء وما
وكيف هي عمليات التنسيق على ارض الميدان
الفقره القادمه ايضا نتحدث انه فيما يتعلق
بعمليات الانسانيه التي تعمل عليها
الحكومه السعوديه هي تراعي بطبيعه الحال
كافه العمليات الانسانيه والمواقف
الانسانيه في ظل الازمات الكبيره التي
يعيشها الرعايه بمختلف جنسيتهم هناك في
السودان نعم بعد الوصول الى بورتسودان
والاكيد بانك كنت على متن سفن اخرى او على
الاقل تابعت سلطان مراحل عمليات الاجلاء
كيف ستتم العمليه ما الذي خصصته المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
ما هي الجهه التي
ستوكل لها عمليه مساعده الرعايه
وعمليه مساعده طبعا لصعودهم الى هذه
السفينه ومن ثم التوجه من جديد والعوده من
جديد الى جده كيف ستتم ما الاجراءات وما
هي التفاصيل الاضافيه عند وصولكم الى بورت
سودان
هنالك عمليات تنسيق عاليه المستوى بين
الحكومه السعوديه ممثله بوزاره الخارجيه
السعوديه والقوات البحريه السعوديه
واللجنه شكلت من قبل حكومه السعوديه
لملف الاجلاء الرعايه من بورت سودان الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه وكذلك لقاعده
الملك عبد الله الجويه وايضا الى ميناء
جده الاسلامي نتحدث انه الحكومه السعوديه
تقوم بتنسيق مع كافه الاطراف السودانيه
هناك لتوفير ممرات امنه من
العاصمه السودانيه خرطوم برا الى بورد
السودان مسافه تصل الى 850 كيلو ومن ثم
هنالك السفاره السعوديه في الخرطوم عملت
على تجهيز موقع الاستقبال كافه الطلبات
والتنسيق مع الحكومات الاجنبيه وتمت
بالفعل الموافقه على عدد كبير من هذه
الى ما يقارب 2020 شخص منذ بدء الازمه الى
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه فقط نتحدث انه
خلال الايام القادمه من المتوقع ان تزداد
هذه
هذه الفرقاطه السفينه جلاله الملك الجبيل
المتوقع خلال عشر ساعات القادمه سوف نصل
للميناء بورتسودان سوف العربيه سوف تنزل
على ارض وسوف نزور مقرات التنسيق للحكومه
السعوديه وكيف سوف تتم عمليات النقل من
الخرطوم الى ومن ثم الى السفن العسكريه
السعوديه التابعه للقوات البحريه السعوديه
الاكيد باننا سنكون معك في الساعات
القادمه لمتابعه كل هذه التفاصيل ومراحل
عمليه الاجلاء شكرا جزيلا لك زميلنا سلطان
السلمي من على متن السفينه السابعه التي
تتوجه من ميناء جده الى ميناء بورتودان
لاستكمال عمليات الاجلاء شكرا سلطان
ونتحول من جده الى السودان ومعنا من منطقه
المعموره جنوب الخرطوم ورسول العربيه
مراسله العربيه الريان ظاهر ريان اهلا بك
معنا معك كنا نتابع كذلك عمليات النزوح من
داخل او بدايه من جنوب الخرطوم باتجاه
مناطق اخرى ولكن حدثتنا كذلك في نشرات
اخرى عن الصعوبات التي تعيش هذه المنطقه
من حيث انقطاع المياه كذلك محدوديه
الموارد الغذائيه وانت موجوده في داخل
احدى المغازات حدثنا اكثر عن توفر المواد
الاساسيه خاصه فيما يهم هذا الموضوع
بالامس فعلا كانت التغطيه لبعض
المسافرين المغادرين من الخرطوم ربما الى
ولايات اخرى وربما خارج السودان اليوم
وكانت عدد من الشكاوى حول نفاذ المواد
الغذائيه والمواد التموينيه وهو ما يقلق
الكثيرين
وتشير بعض المعلومات الى ان هذه المواد
الغذائيه ربما
تنفذ او لا تكفي لمده اسبوع وما يكون مسار
يعني
مثال
لقلق الكثيرين انا في احد المحاله
التجاريه وعاده كثير من المحاله التجاريه
يعني في هذا التوقيت تكون مغلقه وجدنا هذا
المحل يفتح ابوابه للمشترين
ونود ان نقرا سويا ونتعرف ايضا على الحركه
الشرائيه للنازع المواد الغذائيه سنتعرف
من خلال الاستاذه عاصم الذي هو صاحب هذا
المحل مرحبا استاذ عاصم الله يسلمك الله
يبارك بدايه بتعمل بشكل كامل ولا جزئي
والله في الحقيقه من بدت الاحداث نحن
سرحنا كل الموظفات
وبنشتغل الان بشباب قله معظمهم كلهم مسافر
للعيد او بسبب الازمه ونحن يعني
بنشتغل تحت ظروف صعبه جدا ندره في المواد
الغذائيه
والموردين والشركات اللي هي كلها بتاعتها
مشتقات الالبان وكلها ما موجوده يعني
حاليا كل ده الاسطوك الموجود في المخازن
نحن كله جبناه
وخطيناه
لكل المواطنين فتحنا ابوابنا واقفين معاهم
يعني بنشتغل كيف الاقبال الحركه الشرائيه
والله كان الشراء في بدايه الازمه كان
بهلع شديد جدا
وخوف وطبعا كان اثناء القصف والضرب
والرصاص الناس كان بتيجي يشتري في ساعه
الهدنه
والمواد شنو يقبالن عليها والله ما في
حاجه يا اخي كل الاشياء كل المواد
الغذائيه الناس دي اخذتها ما عدا المنظفات
والحاجات اللي هي لها علاقه
هل في بعض الغلاء للاسعار ولا هي كما هي
والله بالنسبه للخضروات هي شويه في ارتفاع
في الاسعار الخضروات واللحوم
ويعني بعض اللي هو الفراخ البيض دي
الحاجات القدر توصلتنا وصلتنا باسعار
زايده يعني لكن باقي موادنا اللي هي
موجوده في المخازن وفي الرفوف بنفس
الاسعار نحن
بنبيع على الجمهور يعني
كل او الحياه كلها اصحاب المحلات انا
بدعوه منه يفتحوا محلاتهم للجمهور ويعني
والموردين برضو اللي هم شركات الالبان
ومشتقاتها
وكل الشركات اللي هي بتاعه المواد
الغذائيه انها هي يعني تورد المواد والناس
كلها تنزل دوامها عادي يعني ناسي شغالين
ولله الحمد كل الناس دي معانا هنا وبتقضي
في حاجاته وما في حاجه يعني انا يعني بقول
لهم انه الهلع والخوف ده
وان شاء الله كل الامور يعني
بتصير بصوره طيبه يعني ايضا معنا صوت احد
المواطنين مرحبا
اولا احيي قناه الحدث على اهتمام الدعم
بقضايا السودان
ونسال الله ان يرفع هذه الازمه عن الشعب
السوداني
حقيقه هذه كارثه
احلت بالشعب السوداني
والملاحظ هذه الايام ان معظم المواطنين قد
هجروا
منازلهم الى الولايات والارياف بسبب
الظروف الامنيه
ونتيجه لذلك كثير من اصحاب المحاله
التجاريه كذلك اغلقوا محالهم
وذهبوا كذلك الى الولايات حيث الامن الذي
حدث بعد ذلك ان هنالك قليل من المحاله
التجاريه هي التي تعمل
هذه المحال بكل مواطن سنون الالبين قصك
حاليا في البيت من مواد غذائيه وتنمويه
والله
المواد التموينيه
الاشكال في المواد التموينيه انها غير
متوفره بالحد الكافي بسبب ان ان كثير من
المحاله التجاريه اغلقت ابوابها وبالتالي
المواطن يعاني في البحث والوصول الى المحل
التجاريه هذا اولا الامر نعم الاسعار بكل
اسف تضاعفت اضعافا مضاعفه وهذا امر سيء
حقيقه لانه
المطلوب في مصلحه هذه الظروف ونحن كشعب
سوداني شعب معهود عندنا التضامن ان يكون
العكس تماما ان يكون هناك تخفيف على
المواطنين بتخفيض الاسعار هذه نقطه
الملاحظ كذلك غياب تام حقيقه
لوكالات العون الانساني للمواطنين هناك في
المياه حقيقتين يعني هنالك شحف في المواد
التموينيه هنالك الشحف الادويه معظم
المستشفيات قد تضررت وبالتالي في مثل هذه
الظروف كان المطلوب ان تكون هنالك مراكز
صحيه في الاحياء على الاقل يستفاد من
الكادر الطبي الموجود في كل حي وكذا مواقع
للمواد التنوينيه نتمنى ان حقيقه يعني
وكاله العون الانساني تسهم في هذا ولكم
التحيه والتقدير الجميع اذا هي اصوات
المواطن السوداني ايضا شح المواد
التموينيه
وبعض الارفف تبدو خاليه تماما يعني بعض
الارفف نفذت منها هذه المواد وصعوبه
استيراده هم فقط
يستوردون من المخازن ايضا هنا بعض الارفف
هنا الارز
وهنالك ارفف فارغه تماما
وبالتالي هي شكاوى المواطن السوداني من شح
هذه المواد ومن الخوف والقلق من نفاذها
نعم وحدثنا كذلك ريان عن مخاوف من
المستقبل من ان تنفذ هذه المواد الغذائيه
بشكل تام في المستقبل على كل سنبقى معك
لاستكمال هذا التفاصيل بخصوص الظروف
المعيشيه التي يعيشها السودانيون في هذه
المرحله من الازمه السودانيه ساكتفي معك
بهذا القدر حتى الان ريان ظاهر مراسله
العربيه من احدى المحال التجاريه في جنوب
الخرطوم شكرا جزيلا لك
ومشاهدينا بالعوده لجهود السعوديه بشان
المساهمه في اجراء الرعايه الاجانب عبر
موانئ جذاب البحر الاحمر وصلات الفرقه
الفرنسيه لوغان الى جده وعلى متنها اكثر
من 400 شخص قدمين من السودان هربا من
الاقتتال الدائر نتابع
الان بدا نزول
الاشخاص على متن او رعايه بعثه الامم
المتحده ونشاهد ايضا هذه السيده والتي
ترافقها احدى المجندات السعوديات من الحرس
من حرس الحدود وكذلك جنود من حرس الحدود
يرافقونها في عمليه نزولهم وهي من الدفعه
الاولى طبعا الفئات المخصصه للاحتياجات
الطبيه هم يقومون به الان النزول والمتوجه
مباشره الى مركبه الاسعاف كما نشاهد التي
خصصتها الصحه وهي هيئه الهلال الاحمر
السعودي وكذلك السلطات السعوديه وتامين
صحه وسلامه رعايه بعثه الامم المتحده تحمل
هذه الفرقاطه قرابه ال400 شخص من جنسيات
مختلفه هناك السلك الدبلوماسي لعدد من
الدول سواء الدول من اوروبا وكذلك امريكا
وهم ايضا سوف يستقبلون بعض رعاياهم من
بعثه الامم المتحده يتواجدون الان هنا على
رصيف ميناء جده الاسلامي هنا ايضا وصول او
نزول ايضا المزيد من بعثه الامم المتحده
ورعايته الامم المتحده الذين وصلوا للتو
الان
الى ذلك كانت ساهمت سفينه امانه السعوديه
باجلاء مئات الاشخاص من مختلف جنسيات
العالم مسجله بذلك اكبر عمليه اجلاء من
السودان حتى الان نتعرف مشاهدينا على هذه
السفينه
سفينه امان السعوديه تقوم باكبر عمليه
اجلاء من السودان السفينه ترفع علم
السعوديه منذ 44 عاما
ايطاليه الصنع تملكها شركه نماء للتجاره
الدوليه عرضها يصل الى 23 مترا وطولها
لمئه وثمانيه واربعين مئات الرعايه
الاجانب استخدموها لتنقلهم من ميناء سواكن
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده
يصلون لوجهتهم المستقره وتغمرهم فرحه
النجاه يلوحون لها شكرا امانه على الامانه
يعني هو الرعب الطياره من فوقك كيف هيك عم
تقصف يعني رعب كان فظيع مذيعه يا محمد
معانا
يعني رعب نفسي وجسدي
والله كنا بالسودان بالعاصمه الخرطوم في
الخرطوم نفسها الخرطوم نفسه وكان فيه يعني
نسمع اصوات تقريبا كذا واخر فتره لما
قلبنا انه خلص بدنا نطلع فكانت الضرب قوي
جدا يعني صراحه كان كل شي منظم ما شاء
الله وكان كذا في جنود وكلهم قاعدين
يعطونا ترتيبات يعني فكان الموضوع جدا سهل
الحمد لله وصلتوا مع السفاره السعوديه هنا
ايوه اهلي من هنا تواصلوا معاهم قالوهم
قالوا لهم نروح على الميناء البري البحري
استغلال استغلال ذاته بشر
ة يعني
ومشاهدينا نذكر بتطورات الميدانيه في
السودان فرغم الهدنه المعلنه تشهد العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم اشتباكات مستمره بين
طرفي النزاع اي الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم
السريع ويظهر لنا هنا ان الاشتباكات تركزت
في محيط القصر الرئاسي الواقع وسط العاصمه
قوات الدعم السريع اتهمت الجيش وقالت انه
هو من هجم قوتها بمحيط القصر الجمهوري
وارض المعسكرات وسوبا في وقت واحد ونجد
هنا كذلك الاشتباكات وقد امتدت الى مناطق
في محيط القياده العامه واداره المرافق
الاستراتيجيه الجيش اعلن تصديه لتلك
الهجمات التي تشنها مجموعات الدعم السريع
ويظهر لنا كذلك اشتباكات في المناطق
المحيطه بمطار الخرطوم الدولي وحي المطار
السكني وعن قناصه الدعم السريع المستمره
في اطلاق النار بمطار الخرطوم وبحري وام
درمان وفق اعلان الجيش السوداني ومن
الخرطوم الى ولايه غرب دارفور فقد تجددت
للشبكات في مدينه الجنينيه بين الجيش
والدعم السريع وسط الاحياء السكنيه
متابعه هذه التطورات بالنقاش مع ضيفنا من
لندن الكاتبه الصحفي خالد العيسى سيد خالد
اهلا بك معنا هذه الهدنه هل تعتقد وانت
خللتها الشبكات قادره ان تبني لمرحله
جديده لوقف دائم لاطلاق نار خاصه مع بعض
التسريبات التي تقول بان هناك وسطات لم
تذكر لم تحدد حتى الان ولكن قادره ان تجمع
الجنرلين على طاوله التفاوض واحده
بالنظر المعطيات السابقه في الهدن التي
اعلنت وفشلت بالتاكيد اصبح من الضروري جدا
تحكيم صوت العقل من كل الاطراف لاسيما
وقوات الدعم السريعه التي فقدت الكثير جدا
من الوطن وهؤلاء جميعا يعني كان يمكن ان
يفيد السودان هذه الموارد التي تهدر اهل
العسكريه الزخائر القدرات الحربيه هي
جميعها ملك للشعب السوداني والدوله
السوداني اذا من المنطقه ان تتوقف هذا
بالاضافه الى فقدان الارواح من المنطقه ان
تتوقف هذه الحرب التي لها كاسب فيها بخلاف
الخسران الكبير للوطن والشعب انا في تقدير
ان الهدن التي اعلنت من قبل فشلت بحكم
الانقطاع التواصل بين العيادات الدعم
السريع وجنودهم على على الارض العمليات
والعراق المسلح وهكذا
هو تحدثنا عن الوساطات والمبادرات بالنظر
الى مكان
صرح به وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان ونحن
بدانا هذه الساعه من التغطيه بما اعتبرهم
مراقبون ملفت وكان هناك تصريح لوزير
خارجيه جنوب السودان قال فيها بان البرهان
اكد لرئيس جنوب السودان سيلفاكير استعداده
للقاح ميسي ويبدو بان التواصل الان جاري
بين رئيس جنوب السودان وحميتي حول هذا
الموضوع هل تعتقد بان هكذا مبادره قادره
ان تدفع او ان تضغط على الطرفين للجلوس
وللتفاوض
بالتاكيد ظلمنا نردد ان المؤسسه الاقليميه
الوحيده التي هي كانت قادره على تقريب
وجهات النظر وطي الازمه السودانيه منذ زمن
بيتها الايجاد من جهه الاتحاد الافريقي
كمنصات حوار وليس رعاه رعاه وليس يعني
اصحابه في الحوار السودانيين ولكن في صعيد
دوله جنوب السودان ايضا كنا منذ اليوم
الاول مبادره الرئيسي الفقير للحلف في
السودان وعندما جاء تودكن يعني اكثر من
مره للخرطوم وانتهى كل الفرغاء مدنيين
وعسكريين وهي كانت يعني المبادره الاقرب
للحمل ولكن اتجه على الجميع العلاقه
القديمه والماكينه بين الرئيس سيرفر
الخرطوم في المكون العسكريه الرئيس
البرهان وانا نائب رئيس المجلس السيادي
محمد حمدان دوغلو من الممكن ان تقرب هذه
المسافات يعني وتزيل هو الكبير والشاسعه
بين الفريقين والرجلين لهما مكانه خاصه في
الجنوب لانهما اشرفا على اتفاقيه السلام
في جنوب السودان ولطالم
اتفاقيه
على الموعد في في الجنوب لكي يطوي الخلاف
بين بين الرئيس الباكير بشار وانا في
تقدير ان الوعاء هذه العلاقه الوجدانيه
الممتده والعلاقات الاستراتيجيه المتينه
وتبادل المصالح والخطوط الاقتصاديه التي
تربط البلدين كفيله بان تغرب وجهات النظر
ولكن يبقى السؤال المهم من سيستجيب من
الطرفين في حال
مدرسه المواقفه في حال غياب الرؤيه انا في
تقديرها ان الطرف الذي عليه ان يبدي رغبه
في التفاوض الان والاشتياب للمبادرات
المعروضه هو قوات الدعم الشريعه التي فقدت
كثير جدا من قدرات العسكريه جدا من
المنتسبين من الجنود الذين هم ايضا ابناء
السودان
لا لا كاسب في هذه المعركه هذه نقطه مهمه
لا كاتب ولا هناك هذه يعني
صحيح ولكن لتقريب المسافات كما تفضلت
بالاشاره يقول البعض بانه يجب ان توضع
شروط او المنتظر ان يضع كل طرف شروطه
لاستكمال هذه المرحله او على الاقل
لتثبيت وقف تام لاطلاق النار بحسب قراءه
حضرتك ما شروط كل طرف
لتحديد هذه الامكانيه او للسعي باتجاه هذه
الامكانيه حتى قبل خروج الطلقه الاولى كان
يمكن لغوات الدعم السريع وقيادات ان تفرص
شروط في صياغه الاجل الزمني والمدى الزمني
وهذا النوع من البنود لكن بكل اسف هذه
الايام التي انقضت يعني ضربت بلا رجعه
فكره ابغاغه الدعم السريع خارج مظله
المؤسسه العسكريه حتى الذين كانوا
يتعاطفون مع فكره عامين او ثلاثه اعوام
لفتره الدمج الان لم يعودوا على على ذات
الموقف الذي حدث في الخرطوم اصاب الامه
السودانيه وجرح مشاعر الانسانيه وضرب
اشياء كانت يمكن ان تؤسس لفكره الحوار
الان الدعم السريع ليس خيار بخلافا يلبو
شعار القرار الذي صدر عن القائد العام
للقوات المسلحه وهو دمج القوات ومن ثم
يمكن التفكير في حوار جديد لكن ما القيمه
من الحوار كانوا يريدون عشره اعوام اخرى
لا يمكن هذا فكر خاطئ خاصه انه الان بدماء
يعني يعني ارتبط في الودان السوداني بان
حاله غير مصبوغه وماساويه وتركت عقيده
وقناعات كامله لدى كلا من الشعب السوداني
بضروره وجود جيش قومي وعد لا يمكن ان يكون
هناك جيش خارج مظله الشرطه القوات المسلحه
وهذا امر حياه او موت الان هذا السودان لن
ينهض من يقوم لن يقف على اقدامه ما لم
تحسم هذه القضيه التي هي اساس كل الصراعات
وهي التي فتحت الباب واسعا في الاختلافات
هذه الازمه كان البواب لعرض اهليه وهذا
اخر ما يتمناه الشعب اكيد اكيد
سنتابع مناقشه كل هذه التطورات ولكن
ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر على مستوى هذه
الساعه من التغطيه شكرا جزيلا لك خالد
العيسى الكاتب الصحفي كنت معنا من لندن
ومشاهدينا قبل المتابعه نذكر ببعض الاخبار
او اخر التطورات التي كنا نتابعها منذ
دقائق قليله في صيغه عواجي الاسفل الشاشه
في اخر التطورات الصحه السودانيه كانت
تحدثت عن ارتفاع عدد قتل الشبكات الى 512
وارتفاع عدد الاصابات الى
4,183 الصحه السودانيه كذلك كانت تحدثت عن
الخدمات الصحيه واكدت بانها مستقره نسبيا
كما وصفات وبان بعض مستشفيات دخلت الخدمه
بعد توقف قبل ذلك كان هناك كذلك خبر
لمفوضيه اللاجئين التي اكدت بانها ستزيد
دعمها للدول المجاوره للسودان لاستقبال
اعداد اكبر من الوافدين ونحن كنا تابعنا
بان هناك حركه نزوح بالداخل وكذلك هناك
حركه لجوء كبيره والان مفوضيه اللاجئين
تتحدث عن زياده دعمها لدول الجوار
لاستقبال اعداد اكبر من الوافدين سنتابع
كل ذلك سنبقى في متابعه هذه العواجل واخر
هذه التطورات ولكن نكمل مع بعض الاخبار
ذات الصله دائما مع هذه الازمه حيث وصلت
اول طائره تقل رعايا قادمين من السودان
الى مطار ستانسد قرب العاصمه لندن بعد ان
اجلتهم الحكومه البريطانيه نتابع
[موسيقى]
هذا مشاهدينا ووصلات ولو طائره اجلاء
تابعه للخطوط الملكيه المغربيه الى مطار
محمد الخامس الدولي في مدينه الدار
البيضاء نتابع
[موسيقى]
واما على الحدود بين مصر والسودان فاقد
اصبح معبر ارقين البري الفاصل بين البلدين
بمثابه طوق نجاه الفارينه من الاشتباكات
حيث عبر من خلالهما لا يقل عن 5000 شخص
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه
معبر ارجين البري يفصل بين الحدود المصريه
والسودانيه افتتح حسب سبتمبر عام 2016
لنقل البضائع والركاب يقع على مسافه 850
كيلومترا شمالي الخرطوم يستوعب سبعه الاف
وخمسمائه مسافر يوميا واكثر من ثلاثمائه
شاحنه بات يمثل طوق نجاه للفرين من
اشتباكات السودان عبر منه الالاف من
السودانيين والمصريين هربا من القتال بعد
اجتياز المعبر يتجه المسافرون الى مدينه
اسوان الوصول اليه يتطلب رحله محفوفه
بالمتاعب تستغرق نصف يوم للوصول اليه من
الخرطوم ومده مماثله للعبور الى اسوان
ونظرا لصعوبه الوضع في السودان سمح
للسودانيين بعبوره بلا تاشيره مسبقه
ومشاهدينا نتابع هذه التفاصيل مع زميله من
جداه نصفيان مراسل العربيه وكان هاني
حدثنا وافادنا قبل قليل بان 1200 معتمر من
السودان مستعد للمغادره من ميناء جده
باتجاه بورتسودان وانت موجود هاني على عين
المكان فحدثنا عن التفاصيل عن الظروف كيف
هي
نعم اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين قناه العربيه
العربيه تواكب ايضا عمليات الاجلاء وكذلك
عمليات المغادره من هنا من تحديدا من
ميناء جدا الاسلامي وكذلك عمليات الاجلال
التي تتم في قاعدتي الملكه فيصل البحريه
وقاعده ايضا الملك عبد الله الجويه ولكن
تحديدا من هذه المنطقه وبداخل صاله
المغادره في ميناء جده ميناء جده الاسلامي
حيث يتم في هذه اللحظات الان استعداد اكثر
من 1200 معتمر هم يستعدون للمغادره
باتجاهنا بورتو سودان او بورتو سودان نعم
بعد انهاء اجراءاتهم وايضا انهاء
الاجراءات النهائيه لمنصه الجوازات
السعوديه طبعا
عدد على هذه السفينه تحديدا وقد يصل الى
اكثر من 2000 معتمر يغادرون لهذه لهذا
اليوم ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه العدد الذي
وصلنا اكثر من 1200 معتبر اذا ما زلنا
نرصد عمليات انهاء اجراءات المعتمرين
المغادرين من السودان باتجاه
ميناء بورتو سودان عبر المنصات انهاء
اجراءات الجوازات التي خصصتها السعوديه
طبعا هؤلاء المعتبرين قدموا في شهر رمضان
الماضي وبعد الاحداث الاخيره التي حدثت في
السودان بين طرفي النزاع قامت الجهات
المختصه السعوديه
بتوفير مقرات اماكن لهم وكذلك توفير
الوجبات اللازمه وكذلك
التي المقدمه لهم حتى حان الوضع المناسب
الان بحسب التقييم وبحسب ايضا رغبه هؤلاء
المعتمرين بالمغادره من هنا وامنت لهم
وامنت لهم السعوديه سفينه خاصه سوف تغادر
في مسائي هذا اليوم في تمام الساعه
الثامنه مساء اي بعد ساعه من الان على هذه
المنطقه تحديدا هي منطقه الجوازات يتم
انهاء الاجراءاتك في غضون ثلاثين ثانيه
اذا نتحدث عن ايضا الكشف او او اخذ
العلامات الحيويه عبر البصمه وكذلك
التقنيات الموفره في الجوازات السعوديه
وبعد ذلك يتوجهون مباشره الى البوابه
الخاصه كما نشاهده هناك من قبل لو يلتقطها
المصور هم يستعدون
لاخذ او التوجه الى حافلات التي سوف تقل
لهم الى السفينه الخاصه طبعا السفينه سوف
نرصدها في النشرات القادمه ولكن احببنا ان
نرصد الوضع الحالي بالنسبه للمعتمرين من
السودان اذا اخذنا لو نجري لقاء سريع مساء
الخير عليكم السلام ورحمه الله مرحبا بك
مساء المعتمرين
متى جيت وفي اي شهر رمضان او قبل ايوه جيت
في شهر رمضان طيب بعد الاحداث اللي صارت
في السودان الان وصارت العمليه عالقه وش
الاحداث اللي صارت هناك هل تم توفير لك
سكن هل انت كنت برغبتك تسكن بالحالك اعطيه
التفاصيل ايوه انا جيت لحالي
فجزاههم الله خير الناس اهل المملكه وفروا
لنا سكن وكل شيء فالحمد لله الان انت متجه
بورتو السودان
الاحداث اللي سوف تواجهك ماذا تتوقع
والله عموما كده الاخبار التي وصلتنا
البلد اماني الحمد لله الطريق في اي منطقه
البلد امان في اي منطقه او في كل ولايات
السودان الطريق امن قالوا فما عدا الخرطوم
فالحمد لله ان شاء الله هنوصل اهلنا باذن
الله سالمين امنين طبعا بيستقبلكم او سوف
تستقلون حافلات بهناك او كيف وسيره
المواصلات انت في اي منطقه في السودان او
في اي ولايه نحن في ولايه القضارف
فالباصات موجوده من بورسودان للقضارب
موجوده متوفره
[موسيقى]
الى ولايه ومتوفره ايوه ان شاء الله
وانت مرتاح
ومرتاح خالص الحمد لله
لكن انا شفت بعض المعتمرين انه ياخذون
وجبات مجففه يعني شروها بكميات كبيره
موجوده كل شيء موجوده الحمد لله موجوده ما
شاء الله يعني ليش ماخذين الكميه هذه
الكبيره يعني
طريقه السفر وكده
مع سلامتكم توصلون بالسلامه ان شاء الله
اذا هذا احد المعتمرين في مدينه القطارف
وسوف يتجه وهو يقول ان الطرق امنه ولكن
منطقه الخرطوم تحديدا او مدينه الخرطوم هي
ليست امنه هناك من يستقبلوه هناك ايضا كما
اوضح ان هناك حافلات ولديه معلومات واضحه
بالنسبه لما اخبرنا به وهذا بدليل ان هناك
تنسيق بينه وبين اقارب له او عائلته هناك
فهم يطمئنون على هذا الحال عموما منهم من
يقول الوضع هناك ازمه كبيره ومنهم من يقول
الوضع امن ولكن اهل السودان اعلم
بديار ولكن رصدناه هنا رصدنا انهم قاموا
بشراء الماكولات الخفيفه والمجففه بشكل
كبير
ونشاهد ايضا غير الحقائب الخاصه بهم هناك
بعض الصناديق
التي تم
شراء فيها بعض البضائع المجففه مثل
المكرونه او المعلبات المجففه وكان
استفساري لبعض المعتمرين لماذا هذا الامر
قالوا لا نعلم ما هو الوضع هناك الحالي
بالنسبه للازمه الغذاء وكما ايضا من خلال
التصريحات التي صرح فيها اليوم السيد
الطيب ادم وهو ممثل الامم المتحده للطفول
والذي تحدثوا لنا في داخل السودان ازمه
مياه وازمه غذاء وايضا يواجه ازمه صحيه
وهذا بحسب حديثه وهنا قد قد يكون
للمعتمرين وجهه نظر اخرى في شراء مقتناهم
لهذه البضائع المجففه شكرا جزيلا لك هاني
على كل ما وفيتنا به من تفاصيل نعود لك في
سياق نشراتنا القادمه هنصفيان مراسل
العربيه شكرا لك
ومشاهدينا متابعه لكل هذه التفاصيل من
اندرمان ينضم لنا صحفي مقداد حسن مقداره
اهلا بك معنا انت موجود في يندرمان واليوم
كنا تحدثنا او يمكن القول بان هناك عنوان
رئيسي خاص بهذه المنطقه وهو الطوابير
الطويله من السيارات التي كانت تنتظر
الوقود هناك عنوان ثاني كذلك سناتي
بالحديث عليه وهو
كانت هناك دعوات من داخل مستشفى ام درمان
وحديث عن او تحذير من انهيار وشيط للنظام
الصحي ولكن مبدئيا حدثنا عن ازمه الوقود
كيف تبدو في هذه المنطقه وهل نحن دائما في
اطار الهدوء الحذر
وبجميع المشاهدين العربيه نعم في جولتنا
الميدانيه لهذا اليوم
تحديدا في المنطقه الشماليه لام درمان
الثوره هنالك هدول في في
عجله الحياه الطبيعيه هنالك نعم يوجد حدود
حذر مع كل هذه الطوابير صوابير الوقود
وكذلك جزء يسير جدا من تعبير الخبز يسال
لان هذه المنطقه الشماليه يمكن ان تاتيها
امدادات غذائيه وامداداتها الوقود من
مناطق تعتبر اقل خطوره واكثر امان نسبيا
بالنسبه للوضع الصحي في ام درمان نعم كانت
هنالك نداءات من
الكوادر الطبيه التي توجد داخل مستشفى ام
درمان بان الوضع الصحي اصبح في غايه
الصعوبه وانهم يناشدون الاطباء والكوادر
الطبيه بان تدعم الموقف الطبي لرفع
الحرج او لرفع
المشاكل الصحيه التي تواجههم هنالك وان
الكادر الطبي يواجه مشاكل امنيه كبيره
للوصول الى المستشفيات خصوصا وان منطقه
كان هنالك بعض القذائف التي وقعت داخل
مستوصف يقدم استشارات طبيه كبيره وهو في
المنطقه
تحديدا المركز الرومي
نعم شارع الوادي من الشوارع في منطقه
شماليه اليوم درمان او منطقه كرري وهو يصل
من منطقه القديمه جنوبا حتى الكليه
الحربيه شمالا ومنطقه وادي سن العسكريه
وكذلك المناطق الشماليه بطريقه الشمال هذا
الطريق في في بدايه الاشتباسات في الخامسه
عشره من هذا الشهر او من اخرين كان هنالك
اشتباكات عنيفه في الايام الاولى بين قوات
الدعم السريع وفينا الجيش السوداني لكن
هذا الشارع يشهد هدوء نسبي تماما هنالك
حركه نسبيه في المواصلات وفيلمبات الوقود
مع اتفاظ المواطنين
وكذلك اقبالها الكبير في
المحاله الاداريه لتامين احتياجاتهم
الغذائيه شكرا جزيلا لك مقداد حسن صحفي
كنت معنا من ام درمان
ومشاهدينا في تداعيات هروب عدد من رموز
النظام السابق من سجن كوبر بالعاصمه
الخرطوم اكد الجيش السوداني ان رئيس
السابق عمر البشير لا يزال محتجزا بمستشفى
عسكري تحت حراسه الشرطه القضائيه وقال
الجيش في بيان لهون البشير وعدد من قياده
حزبه محتجزون في مستشفى علياء العسكري
الجيش عبر عن رفضه لاي محاولات لربط ما
يجري في السجون بمزايدات على مواقفه
الوطنيه ووصف الجيش السوداني الدعم
السريعه وقائده بانهم امتداد للنظام
السابق
واما الشرطه السودانيه فاقد حملت قوات
الدعم السريع مسؤوليه اطلاق سراح السجناء
بالاضافه الى الجرائم المرتكبه بحق
المواطنين واكدت الشرطه ان الدعم السريع
اطلق سراحا نزلائي في سته سجون بالخرطوم
والولايات الاخرى الشرطه قالت ايضا ان قوه
الدعم السريع اقتحمت سجن كوبر ويتسببت في
قتل وجرحي عدد من قوات الشرطه
في المقابل اتهم المستشار السياسي لقائد
قوات الدعم السريع يوسف عزت اتهم قيادات
مواليه للبشير في الجيش بالمسؤوليه عن
اطلاق سراح قياده النظام السابق من سجن
كوبر واضاف في تصريحاته للعربيه ان مغادره
قياده نظام البشير للسجن كان امرا متوقعا
بحسب قوله
هو اللي انقلاب الحركه الاسلاميه الذي
يدبره على كرتي نتوقع كل هذا العناصر
الاسلاميه داخل الجيش انا لا اتهم كل
الجيش الجيش ليس كله حركه اسلاميه هنالك
ضباط شرفاء ولكن هنالك جهات داخل
الاستخبارات العسكريه هنالك جهات الضباط
اسلاميين ساهموا في اطلاق سراحه هذه
المجموعه نحن لدينا معلومات من داخل السجن
لحظه اطلاق النار لحظه اقتحام السجن لحظه
اطلاق سراحهم ولكن كانت قواتنا لم تكن
قريبه من الموقع
للسيطره على هذه العمليه
وبالحديث عن سجن كوبر الذي غادرت منه
قيادات من نظام البشير ابرزهم احمد هارون
فهذا السجن يقع في بحري بالعاصمه الخرطوم
ويبعد عن المستشفى العسكري نحو عشرات
كيلومترات اي حوالي سبعه عشره دقيقه
بالسياره وبحسب الجيش السوداني يرقد
الرئيس السابق في المستشفى العسكري تحت
رقابه امنيه قبل اندلاع الاشتباكات
حول هذا الموضوع نسال ضيفنا من الخرطوم
محمد الصادق عبد العزيز السكرتيرو السياسي
لحزب الاتحاد الموحد والقيادي في قوى
الحريه وتغيير المجلس المركزي اهلا بك
معنا سيد محمد صادق الى هذه التغطيه سيد
محمد الصادق حديث عن هروب رموز النظام
السابق لا نتحدث عن عمر بشير التي اكدت كل
الاطراف بانه متواجد في المستشفى ولكن حتى
بعض الرموز بعض الاسماء الكبيره التي نجحت
في الهروب هذا اعتبره البعض تطور خطير
حضرتك كيف تقرا هذا التطور
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بالتاكيد هو تطور
كبير
له علاقه بالحرب الدائره الان
نحن في الحزب الاتحاد المواحد في المجلس
المركزي لقوه الحريه والتغيير كنا قد
اشرنا سابقا وكررناها مرارا وتكرارا ان
للنظام السابق واعوانه دور كبير في اشتعال
الصراع العسكري الذي يدور الان بين القوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع فلذلك هذا
متوقع ونعتقد ان البيان الذي ادى به
بالامس احمد هارون
قد شكل ضررا بالغا على السيده الفريق اول
البرهان القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
وهذا لابد من للجميع ان يعلم ان ان هناك
ثوره قد قامت من اجل
تغيير النظام السابق واطلاعه وبناء سودان
جديد بمفاهيم جديده
نحو الحريه والسلام والعداله هل افهم من
حضرتك بانك تشير لانك وكانك تلمح الى ان
المخطط كان باطلاق سراح عمر البشير كذلك
ومن معه داخل المستشفى ولكن بعد صدور
البيانات ربما تاجرت هذه الخطوه
حقيقه عن مخططهم ماذا
كانوا وان كنت اعتقد انه من الاسلم
والاضمن
للرئيس السابق البقاء في
المستشفى
حتى لجمعه وكرامته
لانه الهروب لا يليق بمنصب رئيس سابق
فلا ادري هل هو مكان ايضا يخططون لهذا
متوقع في سياسه اي شيء يحدث لكن لا اعلم
لكن ما حدث حقيقه حول هذا الموضوع وحول
امكانيه
هروب تم نفيها ولكنك سيد محمد الصادق قررت
لاكثر من مره بان هذا التطور كان متوقع
متوقع لما تقول حضرتك متوقع اي ان هناك
اطراف يمكن ان تخطو مثل هكذا خطوه نتحدث
عن مسؤوليه من في هكذا تطور
نحن منذ بدء العمليه السياسيه
وفي الورشه الاخيره ورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري والتي لاحظنا من خلالها كنت
مشترك في هذه الورشه والتي لاحظنا من
خلالها بدء التفجر الصراع بين الجيش
والدعم السريع حاولنا ان
نصفي النيران حفاظا على السودان
لكن الامور سهرت في اتجاه اخر وكنا قد
اشرنا مباشره الى النظام السابق
يخطط لشيء ما وقد يعمل الكثير من الاشياء
لذلك
نعتقد ان النظام السابق مع زالت لديه في
الدوله العميقه قوه وهذه
يمارس من خلالها
ما يريده من اهداف وهذا ما طلبنا به منذ
بدايه الثوره لكن الثوره لم تستطيع ان
[موسيقى]
تحقق كامل اهدافها في مجال التفكيك ونزاله
التفكيك محمد صادق وسنكون معك في نشرات
قادمه كذلك لمتابعه تحليل كل هذه التطورات
شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم محمد صادق عبد
العزيز السكرتيرو السياسي لحزب الاتحاد
الموحد والقياده في قوى الحريه وتغيير
المجلس العسكري
ومشاهدينا هذه الساعه انتهت ولكن تغطيه
العربيه لا زالت مستمره
للتطورات الازمه السودانيه بعد قليل ليال
تلقاكم لاستكمال كل هذه التفاصيل ابقوا
معنا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات